actually like theme parks oh yeah of
course we have some really good theme
parks actually uh no alton towers if you
like if you like the thrill rides okay
here's the thing because it's actually
really good yeah yeah so if you like the
skype when you go to the theme parks do
you what do you like the thrill rides or
do you like kind of like
okay
so good people lost their legs on it
yeah
wait
okay it has the most loops in any single
uh
uh roller coaster i think yeah
unfortunately um unfortunately the best
rides are every time you go they're
probably going to be closed down for
some reason
as they always are
i can't remember that one ride in like
orton towers or thor park that was just
like the big oblivion
was it oblivion i can't remember
yeah okay so one thing i've never
understood is theme parks that i guess
are actual theme parks right because to
me theme parks are the thrill rides i
only care about the rights i don't i
don't give a [ __ ]
what kind of theme it is i don't give a
[ __ ] what the characters are basically
what i'm trying to say is i don't give a
[ __ ] about disneyland yeah yeah yeah
yeah
you're really like you're really
throwing [ __ ] at disneyland right now
i'm going i'm going to six flags and go
to disneyland yeah yeah that sounds more
like yeah that's why i don't go to
disney parks because i don't care about
three i don't know what's wrong with me
but when i go to disneyland i just feel
this like creepy corporate energy
of like
i'm trying to shove shove some kind of
happy childhood on me that i didn't have
it is kind of like happy pills isn't it
it is it feels like something out of
black mirror when i'm in disneyland
i know it's you like going to this i
know it's not australia no i hate things
i'm not saying everyone who goes to
disneyland is being like [ __ ] uh fed
some kind of fake i understand if you
grew up with it you like that that's
that's totally fair but for me when i
feel i'm there i get this like weird
energy that i'm just like
i i just don't like theme parks in
general because i don't like thrill
rides i don't like roller coasters or
anything like that and it's the same
thing it's like to me the amusement
parks are the thrill rides and the
roller coasters so if you don't like
throw rise and roller coasters i'm not
going to like music i'd rather go to
like the movies i think it's because i'm
over the age of 12 i think as well i
think that well with disneyland yeah but
i think that's all
amount of people i know that you've just
called out with that one basically every
every female in japan
you're called out i know they're it's a
big thing at disney adult and you know
and there's a lot of disney
theme park youtubers yes did you know
that yes yes i know i know i know some
of them and like when i watch them yeah
it's like they're speaking in like a
foreign language to me i don't
understand well what do you mean because
they like they discuss like the optimal
route for like disneyland they all argue
about what the optimal route of
disneyland is and to me i'm like how
about how about you just all just get
turned up
[Music]
do you need to like plan everything well
yeah have you been okay what are the
what is the selling point of disneyland
i don't know i want to know
do you like it i think we're not the
ones we're not the right ones
because you're you're the closest person
to a disney person that is true my
girlfriend is like disneyland why
osmosis yes you must know kind of okay i
really i really i'm not trying to insult
you
who has a girlfriend who was a disney
fanatic
i can say that i think it's just like
the thing is though she like aki's not
the kind of person who goes to
disneyland by themselves because there's
a lot of people who do that
she's like i go that's crazy with other
people to like kind of show them around
if it's their first time or like you
know just to see like what's updated and
just like kind of enjoy the rides
obviously and enjoy like all the
activities that you can do with theme
parks and stuff what activities are
there what do you do
i don't know i don't go with her
you must have been with them once before
i've been with her once what did you do
i waited around until she was finished
with the ride because the theme park the
teamwork
and and ate a bunch of popcorn i don't
have a strong appreciation for the
characters and stuff i think that's what
it is because she's a kingdom hearts fan
so naturally she's going to like disney
[ __ ] as well okay what how do you feel
about they say the universal studios or
that kind of thing then well i i i like
universal studios over disneyland i felt
like you were more sure
as well you know i kind of yeah it
didn't feel as intense i there's
something i don't know it is more chill
than disneyland i feel like i understand
that um
you know theme parks have like those
actors that are there
for like the kids yeah yeah yeah but
there's something just weird about it
when they like
for me i'm like whoa when when an actor
person tries to like speak to me
and i'm in character and i'm like
probably no i don't have a problem with
it i'm just like i'm like confused i'm
like
oh
what
i don't know why it freaks me out i
don't know it i don't know because it's
not really you want them to be in
character you don't want them to be
happy
kinda
but i know they like it i think it's a
british thing that i'm just like i can't
i'm like you shouldn't be happy i'm like
just talk to me like a normal person
i don't care if you're tarzan
that's like real-life fee tubing yeah
right
i don't know i don't know i i really i
think i'm just
too british in some senses yeah i think
that's my excuse for a lot of things i
don't really wrap my i don't know why i
can't wrap my head around it what's
wrong with you i think it's because like
you know like the meta behind it like
you have to kind of be better yeah i
can't immerse like you have to immerse
yourself i think that's the best way to
enjoy like disneyland or anything like
that i can immerse myself in like some
like six flags or alton towers because
all i gotta do is just get on that ride
and [ __ ] myself and have a good time but
that's the thing that's the biggest
difference right like disneyland is like
it sets itself up as like it's like
another world it's like another country
or like consonant you know it's like i
have no issues with this now i don't
people think i'm hating on disneyland i
just i i i i can't get into it but like
i always wonder this right i'm like what
if right you made a theme park with all
of these new characters that no one knew
right absolutely brand new characters
and it was exactly like disneyland just
for characters you didn't know if you
went in there you would think it's
creepy because you don't know any of
these characters i guess because you're
like what is this like black mirror if
you went in there
like picture it you can literally just
picture it right it would be like a
black mirror-esque thing if you didn't
know any of the characters right i just
don't even think i'd be able to immerse
myself in the characters so i would just
be like oh look there's a kind of
costume but like it's only not weird
unless you have character unless you
have characters you understand right and
you understand why they're doing these
things otherwise it's like why are these
people like dancing around and
pretending to be happy and
stuff it's just like strange you know
i think you're reading like way too deep
i don't know i think there's something
wrong with it i i actually agree i don't
like happy people
you know the uk is the uk the uk has
trained me well okay so what can i say
okay i do like happy new year i do like
here i do like happy people and i don't
know thank god
like the other the two british people
and i'm just like i get you connor it's
weird it's weird to me too i've never
enjoyed the seeing people in college you
would be freaked out if you went to a
place with no explanation with
characters that you didn't know just
doing this stuff
and like it's all branded and all stuff
right it would be weird yeah
i don't know what do you think jason am
i crazy would it be weird
start that's the start of the story yeah
well you don't you don't go into a debut
stream commenting being like uh am i the
only one
come on i got it i got it okay a theme
park
with v tubers
the roller coaster model
do you normally go to theme parks case
on have you been to any of the theme
parks here in japan i want to go fuji
japan yeah i went to fuji fuji
foreign
that's the one i want to go to yeah yeah
and i went to disney world with my
friends disneyland with my friends too
um wait there's a disneyland and a
disneyland
in disneyland there's no disney world in
japan it's disney sea disneyland and
disney land yeah i went there
soon there will be disney sky as
i love learning about i love learning
about disneyland i watch all like
defunctland's videos it's pretty good i
love learning about disney i just don't
like i don't want to go to disneyland i
don't want to go disney i don't know any
good rides in usj
yeah one if you like thrill rides yeah
one the the raptor one the jurassic park
one i don't go on the thorough rides
dude you don't go on the thrill rides i
hate thrill rides what i hate roller
coasters
why why'd you hate roller coasters why
would i pay money to get scared it's not
scared it's a thrill it's adrenaline i
don't like that what
i don't like it you don't like
adrenaline you don't feel adrenaline
when you do something exciting no to me
that's not exciting that's just scary so
that's the only thing i like about
through epoxy i like when you don't feel
like you're that's why i don't go to
amusement parks though we've established
this i don't go to amusement park i
thought it was just disneyland
all amusement parks i don't like
that's what i was saying when i went to
when i went to mario world right at usj
a while back that's that's like the
first time
in like 10 plus years that i went to an
amusement park
because i just i don't find that
enjoyable at all i'd rather go to like
the movies
okay if everyone loves thrill rides
fujiku
i've heard is the best in japan yeah
it's all right yeah that's that's what i
want to go to
like usj maybe because you guys have
been really picking up nintendo worlds
i'm going to call it mario world for a
second have you been to europe yeah yeah
once did you go have you been recently
with the mario thing
no
no i don't know that there's also the
chemistry she just she doesn't know
mario
she called super smash brothers melee
you don't know anything about mario no
wait so it's like i wasn't allowed to
play games when i was little
you didn't play recently
um like any nintendo game at all no well
everyone like grew up with nintendo
right yeah real and now i can't go in
like you can't grow up again i can't
grow up again with it i'm too old so
when did you start playing games and
watching anime then um that was when i
was in college oh my god so basically
when you started streaming then yeah
yeah yeah okay so what were like the
first games you played the very first
one was monster hunter oh okay yeah
checks out
you went you went
you went in deep right from the get-go
jesus christ what's your favorite game
of all time of all time is yakuza series
oh
yeah hell yeah why why are we clapping
it's because it's a good game
it's winning an award or something
it looks fun yeah is is that like jojo
do you have to start it's basically jojo
the game
i know it's basically jojo the game in a
lot of ways but i i heard from my
friends who like yakuza that it's best
to start with yakuza 0. is that would
that be correct is that true is that
true um well yakuza 0 i think is really
the best yeah
to start
i think yeah the one would be right
right better there's a remastered virgin
yeah you don't condone skipping parts
[Music]
so you start with one
and then you go to
three
[Music]
wait so so what what would you say
is the best yaguza game zero
i would say
my favorite yeah
is ishii
ishii do you know ishii
yeah i think that was the
is that like the kishibe rohan of yakuza
is that best
oh it's like a spin-off
but
but um before you play eachine you have
to play all the yakuza series to know
more about it so it's literally the kiss
how would you feel if we started with
that game
um
like if i if i if i message you and said
i'm going to start uh my first yakuza
game and it's going to be yakuza ishin
what would you say to me well i won't
say anything but um
you won't understand it right because
all the characters that
that's on the eachine yeah it's the
character they used to be on the other
series
that makes sense okay it's going to be
hard to understand the characters right
if you start from each it really makes
it see that's how we felt when you
explain that
because like a bunch of the side
characters just turn up in that one yeah
like josuke turns out
i think zero is supposed to be like a
prequel to one
so you can technically start with zero
but it would make more sense if you
played one first yeah
the mechanics because zero came out
after one my brain was already hurting
yeah i'm not doing this
every jojo fan is like yes i understand
completely